awesome game awesome finish and a couple
of great teams a couple of great
quarterbacks somebody had to lose
i feel badly for the bills but i was so
excited for the cardinals with the 32 to
30 victory
capped by the hail murray shireen that's
the game that we re-watched this week
and
let's begin some of these are going to
be obvious but still we have to talk
about this game
if we would have picked any other game
it would have been like what the hell
are they thinking of course it's
bills at cardinals best player on the
field in your estimation
well there are two choices mike and i
knew watching the game of course i
knew on the sheet but i knew watching
the game what your choice would be
but i will ask you this would there have
been any
other receiver on the cardinals team
that could
have made that catch i don't know larry
fitzgerald maybe five years ago i don't
know that he can make it now but no
hopkins is the only one who could have
made the catch
yeah no doubt and so i i picked deandre
hopkins
for that reason it was a great play by
kyler murray there's no question about
that
but deandre hopkins made that and i'm
not sure any other receiver in the nfl
could have made that catch frankly he's
the best receiver in football
he proved that again on sunday by out
doing digs
and he's proving that that was the
second worst trade in nfl history and if
not in nfl history at least in the last
32 years and sorry to bring it up again
mike but you know what the worst trade
nfl history was
herschel walker but this might be the
second worst trade in nfl history a
horrible trade
and i know the texans were probably
texans fans at least were sick
watching that catch because it was
amazing
and he made it with three guys around
them and again
i'm not sure anybody else in the nfl
makes that catch he made it
i let me just put my all pro vote right
now and i'm checking off deandre hopkins
as one of my two receivers
now i'll agree with you that no other
receiver on the team
could have made the catch if you'll
agree with me that no other quarterback
on the team could have made the throw
because that's the other side of this
and
and here's the key it's buying time
because my player the game obviously
kyle murray it's buying time
before you make that throw and what i
was reminded of when i watched that play
you see him skirt away from
the bill's defender who had a shot at
him
and it reminded me of that little mini
controversy from week three or
four when jerry jones was talking about
dak prescott
having the mobility and athleticism to
extend a play but then
the great ones can can
harness whatever they need to do after
that can get it together again
after that and i remember seeing the
words written thinking he didn't throw
shade at dak and then listening to him
thinking damn
he's saying that can't do what some of
these other guys do
and regardless of what he was saying
kyler murray is one of the ones
who can get twisted up by a guy who has
a shot at him run away from it and
immediately refocus his attention down
the field
and not have to have to need that two or
three seconds to get
reoriented to where he is in relation to
where the receivers
are murray just kept going he made the
throw he told me after the game
he was facing the sideline when he threw
the ball
i mean he cranked that thing up he knew
it had a chance it helped that it was
deandre hopkins
so and for and for me look it was what
kylie murray did all game long too
i love watching him run the ball he's
fearless he's been taking more hits
they've had more design
runs they've got that that read option
look where
everything flows to the right and he
pulls the ball out and takes off to the
left and no one has a chance
as everything's moving in that one
direction he's got
11 rushing touchdowns this year he's
three short of the record set by cam
newton
i think he's going to set it his odds
keep improving to be the mvp it's now
plus 700 he's like
fourth on the list behind patrick holmes
russell wilson and aaron rodgers
he's just fun to watch every week i wish
every one of their games
were played in prime time and i'm happy
that thursday night we get to see him
against russell wilson again
people act surprised mike that he hadn't
thrown a hail mary ever in his career
but this is a guy that was 42-0 in high
school i mean they didn't play that i
need two
games let's be honest no no you need to
throw a hammer hail mary
and he played one year at oklahoma there
was no need in most those games to throw
a hail mary and it did remind me
this game did of the big 12 game and
especially the way it finished
and their offense is starting to remind
me of a big 12 offense because it's
hurry up and i think they're even better
when they go quick
and they're starting to go quick a
little bit more and they're starting to
get it and cliff kingsbury talk a little
bit about that
but mike you remember that uh sea of
hands game i think it was the 74
playoffs with the chargers and dolphins
that's what that picture of deandre
hopkins reminds me of that sea of hands
who was better than you thought after
taking a closer look at the game
well i'm gonna go with patrick peterson
and i think we've seen a regression of
him over the last couple years i mean
when we start talking about the best
cornerbacks in football
his name's not in it it doesn't come up
real quick for me
thinking of the best quarterbacks i
don't think he's there anymore i know he
was asked a couple days ago about
possibly playing
safety someday soon and he kind of him
hauled around and maybe that's a
possibility
but in this game i thought he was really
good and i thought that interception was
really key that he made in the third
quarter there
that set up kyle murray's 15-yard
touchdown run
that put them ahead for the first time
and i thought that was a big play that
he made in that game and i really
thought he played pretty well overall in
that game and i know he had the coverage
on stefan diggs at the end
but he actually had pretty good coverage
on that play it was just a great
throwing catch
by josh allen and stefan dix one guy i
was really impressed by and we talked
about this some on football night in
america but to actually watch the game
and see him make the kicks and
and one hit the goal post and went in he
this is tyler bass the
sixth round rookie draft pick of the
bills entrusted the kicking job to him
and he made three 50-plus yarders
including a 58-yard
yarder and each one was longer than the
rest and each one was a career long
and he looked yeah you always want to
get touchdowns instead of field goals
but if you're
you know in the vicinity of the 40-yard
line between the 35 and 40 and the drive
peter's out and you can get three points
fairly automatically
that's impressive and to actually see
that happen and to see him nail those
kicks is to watch that game back i
i think tyler bass is one of those guys
if he can continue he's going to be
a fixture in the nfl for years to come
all right give me
someone who had a game they'd like to
forget sheree
well i think the choices are obvious and
i went with mario addison
and he had a chance to make the play
when you watch it dj humphreys fell
down and so he had a free release and
kyle murray juked him and
you know it's not the first time that a
defensive
uh lineman hasn't made the tackle on
kyle murray there's been a ton of those
but never in a bigger situation than
that was that a lineman
uh had the angle had the chance to
tackle and make the play he didn't i
know he's had nightmares over that he
ended the game with
with one tackle and i know he wished he
had had one more which was a sack which
would have ended that game
you know i i'm gonna go with two guys
from the defense
on that same play trenavius white and
jordan poyer and the more i watched that
play back look
white went up and this was a point peter
king made yesterday white was trying to
catch the ball not knock it down
and he didn't get a chance to really do
either because jordan poyer came flying
out of nowhere and slammed into his
teammate and knocked him down
knocked knocked tredavious white out of
the way so look
i i understand that
they called the defense they did and
kyle murray suggested that the first
read was
andy isabella doing a crosser and they
were trying to get closer for a shot at
the end zone and maybe the bills could
have had more guys back they still had
three guys around andre hopkins
but if you're a tredavious white you
don't try to catch the ball
and if you're jordan poyer you don't
come in out of nowhere
and slam into your own guy and knock him
away from having an opportunity to maybe
catch the ball or still knock the ball
away so
those guys have to be watching that play
over and over again and despite all the
praise that we're giving
to deandre hopkins those bills players
that were back there made it easier for
him to catch the ball because
white could have just tried to knock it
down and poyer
should have avoided ramming into davia's
white shireen
yeah no question about it mike and they
were all there and
it looked like they had good defense and
that's what i thought he just knocked
him right out of the way maybe if he
wasn't there and it was two on one
they would have had a better opportunity
as as crazy it is
as that is to say yeah i mean as peter
said yesterday this wasn't shaquille
o'neal
trying to get a ball over mugsy bugs i i
think it was good morning football that
had they posted on twitter the tail of
the tape and i expected it to be jarring
and it wasn't it's like
it's not like there's this tremendous
advantage that deandre hopkins had other
than hand size
uh he had three guys around him and a
couple of them misplayed the situation
or maybe hopkins wouldn't have made that
catch not to take anything away from
hopkins he made the catch
but it's not like the bills made it
harder on him to do so all right let's
take a break when we return it's time to
hand out
the week 10 awards we probably should
exempt all cardinals from our awards but
hey
it would look weird if we didn't so i
have a feeling you'll hear some
cardinals names
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports